this is a time when then when they had
um art books famous art i was like
famous french art yeah like titanic
she's all draw me jack
yeah yeah like she's all butt naked
famous art by yeah look at that a couple
[ __ ] right out the gate man
oh yeah now we need some more ladies
there's andrew santino right there
[Laughter]
there he is
red rocket himself dang it's like
santino meet me at 145 though yeah he's
cutting weight there yeah it looked like
he just crossed the atlantic on a
desperate ship from his homeland
yeah but yeah you're right though those
paintings back in the day there's a lot
of white girls with tits yeah
right maybe thick girls near a stream
1600s
big girls narrow stream they were always
a little thick too huh
they always had hips on them and then
they always hide their bush a little bit
with like a twig
a fig or a little bird oh there we go
now yeah baby now we're talking big
[ __ ] yeah
okay
cats in the wild that's brandon
[Laughter]
look at that poor cat too
both their cholesterols are high as [ __ ]
look at that and look catch right there
dangling her feet right there too there
you go
look yeah look at the gut
look at the gut on that little spot
right there look at that guy pretending
he's a gynecologist
get out of dodge buck
damn man look at donut lisa right there
meet me at four pounds
three inches tall that was when art was
art you feel me yeah man that's a
beautiful piece but dude i remember i go
into the back of the library i get one
of the books with the rubenesque ladies
in it man and i would literally just sit
there and just bone her out oh just
drool straight into the book yeah dude i
drew a half a quart right in that ass
drool and boners doug just oh it was
insane i remember
oh yeah man i remember
didn't your mom pick you up good day
like sure was full of shame you know
yeah hiding books i'd have to then yeah
i'd be in there masturbating whatever
and then hiding books and [ __ ] all in
the library dude all of this going on
people are trying to learn people are
trying to do reports while you're
jacking off you look like you guys would
fold the pages and come back the next
day in the library hey libraries are
universal man this is your universe
do whatever you want in there are
libraries still popping though they
still open those [ __ ] up i worked at
a library for two years in high school
how was that it was pretty awesome i
just did the periodicals did you know
where everything was when people were
like um where can i find i could catch
you totally see you in the library sorry
interrupt you go on did you check
non-fiction uh
i was pretty good at it uh but there are
a lot of people like theo i was uh
yeah yeah and they would use the
internet and they would jack off like
there was one guy he was a big indian
scoundrels man i'm pissed i obviously
don't have a picture but jay greengrass
i busted this guy
[Laughter]
this is really horrible i was jacking
off to where's waldo
there there was a child next to him and
he tapped her on the shoulder wait hold
on go on this is another dark world of
wisconsin
all right
but he was looking at stuff on the
computer and and playing with himself
and there was a child next to him and he
tapped her on the shoulder and asked her
to look at it oh no and what'd you do uh
she like ran and screamed and then like
i told the libraries they called the
cops and they took them away you have a
whistle or something do they give you
what you do what'd you get i just
started
waving my arms but you can't be loud so
like this
oh yeah you can't be loud just waving
your arms
[Applause]
need relief look at his offense cause
child to view or listen to sexual
activity oh nick got him tight move dude
good job nick thank you enough
yeah doug
saving one kid at a time so nick was
basically a narc before he
was
did you walk up and girl want to have a
seat
i'm already [ __ ] sitting jacking off
what are you talking about i take
offense to being compared to this guy i
know right yeah that's not nice
he was just hanging out in the airport
unfortunately there's a lot of guys like
theo in those libraries theo's not like
this man dude i was reading books i had
to go right to research the author he's
trying to learn bro find the art and
then touch myself yeah this guy wasn't
learning i see this guy doing shorthand
over here just googling it on the web
jay greengrass yeah obviously native
american
he was he was j.a greengrass obviously
going to assassinate a politician any
day now
did you say you would put your wiener in
between the pages and just squeeze the
books together yeah i would but he
wasn't tapping nobody on the shoulder
you know he was doing it by himself in
the corner i would be pissed if i wanted
that book it was like here you oh my god
dude
why you got your
dick in a [ __ ] headlock with the book
why are you doing that to those books
doug nobody's believing this
hypothetical situation where you want a
book okay that's what i'm finding that's
the only part i'm having don't make this
about me let's go back to you
smashing your dick
yeah [ __ ] my education dude you're
ruining the books good books
they're good books brendan not anymore
yeah well they were like why is this one
all dented up
man this one has honey all over it bro
well the thing is this is before the
internet so you had to just you know
that's as close that's how you did it
you found a good book with something
pervy in it and you
pressure pressed your body into it i
never heard that okay let's go
and the sting and the wing
[Music]
you